we've talked a lot on the show about the
threat to free speech it turns out it's
very
real here's one example last week we
interviewed a man named gennaro lopez
lopez is an elected official in tijuana
mexico
he's exactly the kind of person you'd
think a lot of american journalists
would want to talk to
for months the media have demanded that
the migrant caravan from honduras must
be admitted
into the united states once it gets here
they've told us our country will be
greatly
improved by its presence that's how
immigration works
okay it turns out we can test that
hypothesis
that very same caravan the one they've
been telling you about is now encamped
in tijuana
it's been there for weeks simple
question has the caravan
made tijuana better hanara lopez would
know the answer his job is to represent
the citizens of that city
we've invited lopez on twice to ask
about the caravan
here's some of what he told us
seems that somebody's cleaning up
garbage is there a lot of trash there
there's a lot of trash because what i
was trying to tell you the 360
grew to 6200 and that's when it got out
of hand
so we got another facility it's a big
concert hall
where you can have like 10 000 people on
under
a roof that was on december 3rd
10 days later we invited gennaro lopez
back onto the show to see how tijuana
was doing nobody else in the media
seemed
interested in what had happened to the
caravan as long as the migrants remained
in mexico they couldn't really be used
to attack donald trump
so the press moved on to the next dumb
shiny thing
but we were interested here's what lopez
told us
things aren't getting better they're
probably getting worse
last weekend we issued an ultimatum to
all the hondurans and guatemalans
that are camping out here on the street
they're blocking
the street and they're playing all their
necessities trashing the street
problems are still going on uh there's
been like 280 arrests
it before it was only for drug
possession and being drunk in the
streets now it's for breaking and
entering into homes
trashing the street doing drugs in
public blocking traffic
breaking into homes that's not at
all what cnn promised us was senara
lopez one of those white nationalists
the new york times is always warning us
about
did he make the whole thing up pictures
and all for his own
sick bigoted reasons possibly
or maybe and this was our conclusion
there could be a lesson here for the
united states here's what we said that
night on the show
our country's economy is becoming more
automated and tech centered by the day
it's obvious that we need more
scientists and skilled engineers but
that's not what we're getting instead
we're getting waves of people with high
school educations or less
nice people no one doubts that but as an
economic matter
this is insane it's indefensible so
nobody even tries to defend it
instead our leaders demand that you shut
up and accept
this we have a moral obligation to admit
the world's poor they tell us
even if it makes our own country poorer
and dirtier and more divided
in a fast evolving economy it could be
preferable to import more
engineers and fewer people with low
skills no matter how nice or
well-meaning those people might be and
we always assume they are
that's what we said that was our claim
and it's hard to argue with that
in fact nobody in the left did argue
with it they ignored it
instead they zeroed in on the last line
the left says we have a moral obligation
to admit the world's poor
even if it makes our own country more
like tijuana is now which is to say
poorer
and dirtier and more divided that's what
we said
it's true ask canaro lopez
thanks to the efforts of the american
left he and his city are living with the
consequences
but precisely because it is so obviously
true saying it out loud
is a threat our immigration policy
exists for the profit and the comfort of
a relatively tiny
number of people everybody else gets
shafted including genaro lopez and an
awful lot of people just like him
meanwhile the people profiting from the
policy don't want the rest of us to
think about it too much they want us
just to mouth the empty platitudes
and move on nothing to see here shut up
and go away
those who won't shut up get silenced
you've seen it a million times it
happens
all the time the enforcers scream racist
on twitter
until everybody gets intimidated and
changes the subject to the russia
investigation or some other distraction
it's a tactic a well-worn one nobody
thinks it's real
and it won't work with this show we're
not intimidated
we plan to try to say what's true until
the last day and the truth is
unregulated mass immigration has badly
hurt this country's natural landscape
take a trip to our southwestern deserts
if you don't believe it
thanks to illegal immigration huge
swathes of the region are covered with
garbage and waste that degrade the soil
and kill wildlife
the arizona department of environment
quality estimates that
each illegal border crosser leaves six
to eight pounds of trash
during the journey into our country if
you're interested in more detail look at
the website they've created it's called
arizona border trash it's dedicated to
highlighting and cleaning up the
thousands of
tons of garbage strewn across arizona by
illegal immigrants every year
illegal immigration comes at a huge cost
to our environment
the government accountability office gao
put it this way quote
illegal border activity on federal lands
not only threatens
people but endangered species and the
land itself
illegal aliens and smugglers have
destroyed cactus and other sensitive
vegetation that can take
decades to recover including habitat for
endangered species
one land management official described
another federal property on arizona's
border
as so unsafe and with resources so
destroyed
that it is now primarily used for
illegal activities and no longer visited
by the general public
end quote now keep in mind it's not a
press release from donald trump's
campaign team
that's a federal study from 2002 that
was back when
people could do science without getting
fired for it
the left used to care about the
environment the land
the water the animals they understood
that america is beautiful because it is
open
and uncrowded not so long ago
environmentalists
opposed mass immigration they knew what
the costs were
they still know but they don't care
we do care and we're going to continue
telling you about it we think you have a
right to know
no matter what they say